all right it's time for the friday
mailbag if you have anything you would
like to say to us to me
you can email info at davidpakman.com if
it's praise if it's a criticism if it's
a demand for a correction if it's a
question a topic suggestion a guest
suggestion any of it and unfortunately
even if you just have insults
we can't really prevent you from sending
the email either and we are starting
today with the type of insult that i
have to tell you
i love this kind i get pleasure from
this because it's someone who clearly
is so
in a fantasy world about the size of our
show
that i just love this jeff wrote in and
says it's hilarious watching you post
tin foil hat conspiracy theories and
delusional rants on your tiny youtube
channel you're just a youtuber
stop pretending you're in the same
league as actual journalist or opinion
people you're never going to be like
tucker carlson god i hope not
nobody likes you or respects you even
clowns like propaganda puppet kyle
kolinsky are several rungs above you and
that's not saying much because he's a
laughing stock of youtube political
commentators just like you
so kyle sucks too but you're even worse
so what what do i love about this
we have a program that's been around 15
years
we have a larger
daily audience than many corporate media
shows that only get a few hundred
thousand viewers a day we are in the top
0.1
of all youtube channels we are the
second largest left-wing youtube channel
behind only the young turks this is a
full-time job for me
and multiple employees
we've already done the thing that he
says we will never actually do and as
far as i'm never going to be tucker
carlson that's true in two ways number
one i'm never going to be as immoral as
tucker carlson and number two
i'm never going to have the support of a
multi-billion dollar corporation behind
me because i'm happy doing it this way i
don't want to do it that way
so jeff you know what
you're right and i'm so happy that some
of the things you're saying are true
although many of them are not next email
is from dave dave says question hannity
supports a candidate on his show meaning
handed hannity supported mehmet oz in
the pennsylvania uh republican senate
primary
it used to be that if a station gave
advertising or air time to one candidate
over another candidate it had value that
value counted as a campaign contribution
i wonder if the fec would look at this
as a contribution to certain candidates
and it then be deemed an illegal
contribution if that value went over the
dollar amount set by law
or would they see it as within the rules
of what constitutes a donation or a
political contribution dave is right
that when hannity has a platform the
size of his platform and he says i
support oz for example and remember he
supported trump too so it would apply
there as well
every time that he
supports oz or attacks other people like
hannity would attack kathy barnett
another candidate running in that
primary that has a monetary value
exactly what it is would have to be
figured out but there's no doubt that
that has a monetary value it's in terms
of the fec
and it being considered a contribution i
don't know
but there's also
the aspect of equal time laws
and um i don't know to what degree those
are being enforced and honestly i don't
know at this point even where they
necessarily apply but there was a time
and we were when we started on the radio
we were conscious of this particularly
in local elections when we were up in
massachusetts that's where the show
started and we would interview local
candidates we would kind of be told
you've got to at least offer everybody
in this race the opportunity to be
interviewed they won't all take you up
on it but you've got to give them that
opportunity so needless to say
the
aside from the legality of it
the kind of like unquestioning just kind
of like yeah i guess it's fine hannity
tells us who he likes and it's just you
know he's supporting one candidate over
another and everybody just goes along
their merry business as if there's no
monetary value or influence from that it
is weird
i don't know whether the fec angle
you're going to get too far with
necessarily
next email is from quinn quinn wrote in
about liz cheney quinn says david i
wanted to talk more about the liz cheney
segment you did the other day as a
democrat i feel like it's unfair to say
she isn't an ally i understand she's one
of the people who enabled trump until
january 6th but since then she's put her
career in jeopardy by being one of the
only republicans with a moral red line
it would have been great after january 6
for republicans to have an epiphany
and become civil rights advocating
police reforming marijuana legalizing
socialists but just because she didn't
do a 180 in her values doesn't or at
least shouldn't mean she's not an ally
in this particular fight for
accountability
that said if she really isn't an ally
are there any elected republicans you
think would be thanks for hearing me out
this is fine i mean listen quinn when i
say liz cheney isn't an ally i mean
she's not going to fight with us
for any policy issue
on our side it's not policy to say hey
the results of the election are what
they are
that's not policy so i understand you
know using this very specific
line she's an ally in this particular
fight for accountability
this isn't even really a fight it's just
we have an election and biden won
there was a riot incited and there
should be consequences
but the point i'm making is she's not a
political ally on issues of policy and
substance and i stand behind that while
acknowledging
she is on the side of reason when it
comes to just like the law is what it is
it should be enforced elections have
consequences and they're real i hope
that sort of clarifies quinn
ryan wrote in about debating quote gun
nuts
david sur was wondering what your
thoughts were on how to approach a
conversation with a gun nut
when they have the argument well if
someone had a gun they could have
stopped them for all of these mass
shootings we know that argument is
garbage but just wondering if you had
any tactics on how to handle that okay
so there's a couple different things
that are important to bring up in those
situations first of all
in many of these mass shooting scenarios
you only have to think it through to
realize additional guns would accomplish
nothing for example
the aurora movie theater shooting in
colorado years ago a shooting in a dark
movie theater it doesn't take much of an
imagination to understand
how
adding more guns in a dark room
so that there's more shooting maybe at
the real shooter or maybe not
and then potentially causing imagine
that you're the third guy with a gun and
you come in and you just see two people
shooting at each other
how do you know which is the bad guy
with the gun and which is a good guy
with it's absolute and total chaos
that's number one number two there are
numerous examples numerous examples
of mass shootings where we later found
out there were other people with
firearms there and they didn't act
because of exactly what i'm saying it
was so chaotic these things happened so
quickly
that it didn't actually make a
difference now the counterpoint is
you occasionally hear about a gun
actually used defensively to stop a
situation and that's absolutely and
totally fine
but the bigger more common more
prevalent scenario is that more guns
actually add more chaos and overall
limiting the number of guns that are
floating around would have a much uh
stronger impact on reducing gun crime
and gun mortality
than simply adding more guns to
situation it's it's just the way history
bears it out
ramon wrote in about a famine and says
david in having conversations with my
family there seems to be a consensus
that an overall food shortage is coming
soon i'm a new parent and as many others
my baby is affected by the formula
shortage already as it stands i know
you've spoken about this in the past can
you revisit
many thanks love what you do
the latest i've read is that over the
next four to six months
there may be a shortage of specific
products but there is not going to be a
shortage of any general food group
uh or nutritional source and so what i
mean by that is
you know is it poss and i've talked
about this before
is it possible that
one
type of chicken
might not be available in your local
store yeah that's that's possible
but is there going to be no chicken or
no suitable alternative like turkey
or beef or whatever the case may be
there i've not read that that's really a
concern
recently
you all know i love my sumo oranges this
is arguably one of the top fruits in the
history of the world i would die on that
hill okay the sumo oranges
they're just guns they they come to me
they say sir we can't get them
and so i'm instead getting a super sweet
navel orange now it might just be
honestly it might just be seasonality
maybe this is not a time of year when
the sumos are available but the point is
citrus is available the exact type of
orange i want is not currently available
and it just might be a seasonal thing so
my expectation ramon and i don't have
independent knowledge on this i'm going
from the reporting i've read
is there may be a shortage of particular
products but that no food group
or a nutritional source like for example
dairy
meat
vegetables fruits crackers etc uh not
expecting to see a shortage there if
the reality on the ground changes of
course we will tell you
evan wrote in about being tough on crime
david why don't democrats run on a tough
on crime platform by promising gun
control it's baffling that the party who
says they're tough on crime republicans
is also the one unwilling to do anything
to crack down on guns yeah i understand
the logic of it right which is hey
republicans say they're tough on crime
but they want more guns in more places
and absolutely no regulations we are
actually tough on crime we the left
because we will make it more difficult
to obtain guns and then commit crimes
with them it makes absolutely perfect
sense
the right will defuse those talking
points easily by saying actually guns
make us safer if we don't have guns to
defend ourselves with only the criminals
will have guns we
they have experience with these talking
points evan so what you're saying makes
sense but they will be ready for it
mason wrote in about the buffalo
shooting in my view on the death penalty
mazen says hey david i saw a show not
too long ago where you said you don't
believe in the death penalty
i like to say i don't support it you
don't believe in the death penalty
because the justice system makes
mistakes and those mistakes cannot be
corrected once someone is put to death
i was wondering if your opinion would
change based on the facts of the current
shooting at the buffalo store we have
video evidence that this kid murdered
innocent people as well as a 100 plus
page manifesto with his motives do you
think it's still a better option to let
the kid live the last rest of his life
in prison i do first of all
if we are let's just start first first
with what's the worst punishment
based on my beliefs about what happens
when we die
i believe if you put the kid to death
and we i shouldn't even be saying the
kid we're talking about an adult here
who did something absolutely horrifying
when you put this 18 year old to death
lights go out and that's it doesn't have
to live for decades with what he did
sitting in a prison cell so if you ask
me
what's the harsher punishment it's oh
you're 18
the rest of your life whether it be 60
70 80 more years
you're going to do nothing
you're gonna sit in a prison cell and
that's it it's it's over for you that to
me is the harsher penalty so number one
if we just start with what's the harsher
penalty i would go there
um
and then beyond that
all of my same opposition to the death
death penalty stands the government
shouldn't be in the business of putting
people to death yes he arguably has uh
um given out given up
his right to live freely in the world
okay well take it away by putting him in
a prison cell for life
don't take it away by saying well we'll
also do some killing and then there's
all the other arguments that are made so
no amazing even in this case i am not
for the death penalty couple bonus ones
from youtube droned on youtube said
david calls himself an independent
reporter no i don't i'm not a reporter
i'm a commentator
so funny he doesn't even know if he
identifies as a guy or a girl give me a
break
no i identify as a guy
very confused viewer
also one other from droned who says this
pacman is a joke i cannot wait till this
economy is in world war three and see
what third gender he wants to talk about
i i don't talk about third we barely
talk about gender on the show
and i also while i don't make economic
predictions typically
my expectation is inflation has peaked
and will start to decline
and that we are
getting closer
to the stock market bottom now obviously
that's kind of meaningless we're always
one day closer to the bottom even if
we're not there yet uh but i don't i
don't even know what this person's
talking about and lastly claude wrote in
this pacman guy is just a mouthpiece for
the biden gang what a joke imagine how
much education was wasted to create this
propagandist liar
um yeah i don't the one thing i don't
think you can say about this show is
that we're mouthpieces for the biden
gang in fact
i find biden pretty uninspiring and he's
done you know three or four good things
and
is otherwise exactly what i expected his
administration to be so maybe you're
thinking of another show claude with
respect
send in your emails to info
davidpakman.com we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpackman.com
to get instant access